and promised to take revenge for his
killing islamic jihad claimed the 17
year old as one of his members he was
killed by israeli forces in janine
refugee camp in the early hours of
saturday
the israeli army has intensified night
raids in janine in recent weeks since
the beginning of the year 21
palestinians been killed in the camp
this is also where al jazeera journalist
shireen abuali was shot in the head and
killed by the israeli army she was on
assignment and wearing a helmet and vest
clearly marking her as a journalist but
israel is refusing to launch a criminal
investigation
and now 57 american politicians have
signed a letter demanding the fbi to
investigate
republican congressman andre carson
tweeted the killing of al jazeera
reporter and fellow american shireen abu
akley was not only a tragedy it was an
affront to press freedom and to all
americans adding we need answers and
accountability from the israeli
government
on the day of the funeral israeli forces
stormed the procession and started
beating mourners causing pallbearers to
almost drop her casket
that didn't stop thousands of
palestinians from marching through
occupied east jerusalem to take part in
a funeral and burial israel has
tremendous support within the u.s and
that's the reason why they've been able
to so far resist pressure on opening an
investigation into sharing abu agle's
death however with international voices
growing louder how much longer they can
resist that pressure remains to be seen
imran khan al jazeera occupied east
jerusalem